as the mud slides through roberto lugo's
hands the clay rises to challenge
conventions and retail history through a
new lens
ceramics
has for so long been used by
anthropology to tell us about cultures
what people were eating
what a party looked like
and
i've just felt like my culture and
community has been
absent from that dialogue
lugo ceramics feature portraits of
american icons of color from
abolitionist harriet tubman to the
rapper dmx their faces are emblazoned on
delicately painted teapots and vases the
luxury items of history's colonizers now
vessels to empower those once
marginalized
people that have come before me
through the civil rights movement
through my parents
all that energy has created an
opportunity for me to now have the
autonomy to make artwork lugo was born
to puerto rican parents and raised here
in kensington a philadelphia
neighborhood that struggled with crime
and poverty he had no formal art
education growing up but he was
surrounded by inspiration
my art history classes took place in the
streets seeing graffiti seeing mural art
seeing the portraits painted of black
historical figures in philly that was
the only type of art that i saw and so
ingrained in my mind is this is what art
looks like
lugo says as a young hispanic he was
typecast by teachers as likely to go to
prison he painted graffiti and worked
factory jobs until he enrolled in a
ceramics class and something clicked you
know i'm not the best potter i'm not the
best painter i'm not the best portrait
artist i'm not the best rapper i'm not
the best graffiti artist but i do all of
those things
and the thing that is unique about me is
as eclectic as those things sound they
all actually make sense for the human
experience the fine art world quickly
took notice offering lugo international
fellowships and shows the metropolitan
museum of art in new york is the latest
to display his work
[Music]
but where he feels most accomplished is
here at an art fair in his old
neighborhood turning heads and teaching
whoever passes that they too can defy
expectations holding someone's hands and
teaching them how to make a pot for the
first time
is is a magic isn't that crazy yeah
just showing to them exist and they can
create something
i think that that complicates even their
own narratives of possibility
lugo says this is his greatest work of
all opening young eyes guiding fresh
fingers to create new possibilities and
to reach to the past with pride
heidi joe castro al jazeera philadelphia